une session de recrutement au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est l'idée de l'entreprise thalès
implantée à elancourt 150 candidats ont
été conviés à cet événement
objectif trouver des talents saint
quentinois pour des postes d'ingénieurs
et de techniciens avec un niveau minimum
de bac + 2 on a tout intérêt à favoriser
un bon équilibre entre vie personnelle
familiale et vie professionnelle en
réduisant les temps de trajet et en
apportant des opportunités de carrière
aux ingénieurs et aux techniciens sur le
bassin de saint quentin en yvelines
concevoir le cerveau du rafale c'est la
principale activité du site thalès
d'elancourt des radars des équipements
d'information d'écouté de guerre
électronique et des systèmes optroniques
plusieurs dispositifs pensée est
fabriqué à saint quentin en yvelines
ses conceptions en fait ali est
énormément d'expertisé donc à la fois de
la mécanique de l'électronique de
l'informatique et du logiciel qui sont
en fait maîtrisé par très peu de pays
dans le monde
il ya évidemment un aspect de
compétences techniques mais au delà ce
qu'on recherche c'est des profils cd
caractère c'est des savoir être
nous préparons le futur du rafale et les
systèmes complexes de demain qui ne
seront pas limités juste à quelques
aéronefs mais du système de systèmes et
travailler aux architectures de demain
est un enjeu aussi importante le site
thalès d'elancourt propose actuellement
450 contrats à durée indéterminée